welcome to the second week of our class
on shaping the future of work we got off
to a great start last week with lots of
good discussions on the future of work
on your hopes your aspirations a lot of
discussion about the future of
technology and how it's going to affect
work and some of the worries that many
of you have about this so we'll continue
these discussions will go into more
depth on technology and work down the
way in about the 4th week of class but
to give you a preview i posted a new
note on the discussion board about a big
new MIT project on the future of the
technology in textiles of all industries
we are about to start a big project to
see if we can put some of the ideas of
this course to work in practice where we
shape the future of the textile and
fabric industry with high technology
jobs hopefully good quality jobs with
new training programs so take a look at
that post see if you have thoughts on
how we can shape the future work in that
particular sector but this week will do
three things first the videos that are
posted for this week will give you a bit
of a history of how the social contract
played out and worked well in the United
States and in fact in some other
countries around the world in the past
we do this not to try to repeat history
but to spring forward on the basis of a
good understanding of where we've come
from and what we need to do to build a
new social contract of good foundation
for building a new social contract in
the future second this week we're going
to introduce some new regional
discussion facilitators our MBAs from
the class I'm teaching here on campus
are from all over the world from China
from South Asia from Africa from
Northern Europe from Brazil they will
host discussions about how the issues
we're talking about play out in your
regions of the world and we asked those
of you who are from those areas to join
that conversation we'll even have some
new experts from Australia some
colleagues of mine in the Universities
over there who study and work on these
issues
so I think we'll have a full body
discussion about how the changing nature
of work is playing out in different
parts of our planet to get things
started on your personal career process
this week there's an assignment that
will take you step-by-step through a
process of identifying the kinds of
issues that you're interested in you
have some aptitude toward and then the
kind of educational levels that are
available to get access to the jobs in
fields of interest to you so get started
by going to the assignments page start
that process it'll carry through over
the next several weeks and it's
accompanied by several videos around the
role of education it's changing role and
lifelong learning and a special video by
our colleague Lee dire who talks about
the skills and competencies needed for
jobs of the future so that's what we'll
do this week but before we finish here
let's take a look at what you told us
last week about your goals and your
aspirations for work here's the results
of the poll that you filled in about
your top priority for your work in your
career notice that the top item comes
out to be having a good work-life
balance followed very closely by having
a big impact on problems that are
important to you into society and then
in third place but not too far behind is
the desire to have a good living from
your work experiences these are the same
top three items that your colleagues
last year indicated we're their top
priorities although this year the
work-life balance became a little bit
higher in the ranking so it's very clear
that you want many things out of your
jobs and your careers unlike your
parents as many of you told us who
focused over here on earning a good
living and having a stable job you want
to be able to both have a big impact on
work you want to have a good work-life
balance so you can have a good
opportunity to raise your
children and have a be a good spouse at
home or a partner at home and also earn
a good living so let's focus on how we
do that let me give you a couple of
examples of the rich way in which you
embodied these rankings in the range of
comments in the exercise around
comparing your goals with those of your
parents this one I think captures the
essence of what the poll told us as one
of you said I dream of a well-balanced
work family environment where I can
develop my skills put them to service
for my community and as well get a wage
that allows me to have a decent life so
that I can provide for my family and my
offspring or this one my dream is to
change the world by contributing
something meaningful to it while
maintaining a balanced lifestyle I
consider myself a global citizen this is
something that not a number of you
mentioned that you want to work and live
in a culturally diverse yet an
integrated workplace and lifestyle and
that you want to push your children to
be curious about their world and to push
the limits of what they can do as they
grow up here's another one that it says
particularly about young Millennials and
their interest in working with the
digital revolution my dream is to be
part of the digital revolution driven by
Manila Millennials working at innovative
companies and to make the world a better
place to live and work that theme comes
through again and then finally I want to
earn a living wage and not have to miss
my children growing up this is the world
of work that you aspire to this is the
world of work that we have to create
moving forward so let's get on with the
task this week will focus on your
responsibilities to make sure that you
are prepared to have the right
educational levels to achieve your goals
and your aspirations and then we'll also
look at what made the world of work more
effective in some times in the past in
our countries so that we can spring
forward to think about how we
build a new foundation for the future of
work